hurricane durian gains steam another
mass shooting rocks Texas and Hollywood
celebs target anybody who backs Trump
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show guys I hope you had a wonderful
Labor Day weekend that was something the
labor movement was good for right I mean
the Labor Day weekend was nice just a
random day that you get off also the
rest of this week is short so we will
get through it together we have a lot to
get to today let's start with the latest
on this hurricane so according to the
Washington Post category three
hurricanes Orion has parked itself over
the northwestern Bahamas since Sunday
night I mean this sucker is moving like
traffic on the 405 meaning not at all it
is unleashed a nightmare 24 hour siege
of devastating storm surge destructive
winds and blinding rain with Dorian
perch Paris perilously close to the
Florida peninsula Monday night into the
first part of Tuesday has become the
critical time that is likely to
determine whether the state is dealt a
powerful blow or in less intense scrape
just tens of miles and subtle storm
wobbles could make the difference
between the two scenarios the storm has
come to a standstill over Grand Bahama
Island if it soon starts to turn north
Florida would be spared saurians full
fury it looks right now according to the
storm acts like that is a significant
possibility that it sort of hugs the
coast but doesn't actually slam into
Florida full force if Dorian lumber is
just a little more to the west more
serious storm effects would pummel parts
of the coastline such small differences
in the track forecast will have similar
implications further north from Coastal
Georgia to the Carolinas millions of
people have been evacuated in
expectation that the pasta that this
hurricane could slam into the Florida
coast the National Hurricane Center has
issued hurricane storm surge and
tropical storm watches and warnings from
the Atlantic coast of Florida northward
into South Carolina storm surge refers
to the storm driven rise in ocean water
above normally dry land according to the
Washington Post the National Weather
Service office in Melbourne Florida says
the threat of damaging winds and
life-threatening storm surge remains
high there will be considerable impacts
and damage to coastal areas with at
least some effects felt inland as well
ok so guys if you are in the path of the
hurricane and the authorities are
telling you to move do not be a silly
person move we've seen too many cases
where people stick around and then it
puts people's lives at danger not just
the people who stick around but also
people who are supposed to rescue them
you know there are always these stories
that people who stick around and brave
it
that's not braving it out that's you
being a if they tell you to move
you should move because if you don't
move you're putting yourself at needless
risk so that is sort of the story and
the latest this has not prevented the
media from focusing in on the chief
problem here the chief problem of course
is President Trump because always oh it
doesn't matter what's happening in the
universe President Trump is the black
hole of attention that sucks in all
light and emits none so President Trump
over the weekend as per his usual
routine was riffing because this is what
he does and honestly I find it really
ridiculous I found it ridiculous when
Barack Obama did it I find it ridiculous
when when Bush did I find it ridiculous
when Trump does it this routine where
the president is supposed to go to the
storm center at the Department of
Homeland Security or at FEMA and he's
supposed to oversee things he ain't the
king okay we've got entire staffs of
people dedicated to doing this you'd
think that President Obama knew a lot
about storm relief like that was his
area of expertise when he would Jet Set
into the aftermath of a hurricane and
comfort people again the president was a
reality star long before Donald Trump
was a reality star and the notion that
the president either controls the
weather or has significant impact in how
the weather is taken care of from above
afterward is just ridiculous FEMA
handles it their regulations that govern
how FEMA is supposed to handle all this
in any case President Trump this is not
a fault but he shows up at the
Department of Homeland Security to talk
about the hurricane again I just find it
so off-putting
this godlike emperor figure not Trump
just the presidency who's supposed to
descend from on high and then talk about
hurricanes like they know anything about
here's the president from not knowing
things about hurricanes strong
determined and resilient and we will
support each other and we will work very
hard to minimize whatever the effect of
what's coming at us we don't even know
what's helping us all we know is it's
possibly the biggest I am not sure I'm
not sure that every
the category 5 I knew it existed and
I've seen some category force you don't
even see them that much the category 5
is something that ok so everybody gets
very uptight about Trump saying this
sort of thing ok because this is what
from fellas okay everything that he ever
does is superlative so if a woman is
beautiful she's not just beautiful
she's the most beautiful and if a storm
is big it's not just big it's the
biggest we've ever seen and if there's a
recession it's not just a recession it's
the worst recession in human history and
if it's a great economic boom it's not
just a great economic boom it's the
greatest economic boom since God created
the earth the seventh day huge economic
boom let me tell you okay so naturally
the media go nuts over this how dare
Trump say he's never seen a category 5
hurricane Anderson Cooper is very upset
about this because Anderson Cooper has
stood outside in the middle of rain
water and such so here is Anderson
Cooper being very upset that Trump
doesn't know there have been other
category fives on his watch or something
okay so what makes what you just heard
even more confusing or even weirder is
that multiple category 5 hurricanes have
either hit or threatened to hit the
United States during his presidency Wow
I mean what heroic journalism they're
from Anderson Cooper you mean president
from got a thing wrong well obviously
that means he doesn't care about
hurricanes and then Anderson Cooper
doubles down he says well Trump's off
golfing again there are certain
situations in which I think that the
president is basically necessary and it
seems to me that let's say when an
embassy in Benghazi is on fire and the
president might be needed in order to
determine whether or not American troops
ought to be sent there to protect an
American Embassy that juts heading off
to Las Vegas for a party with Beyonce
and jay-z that might be like not a great
thing to do or if you're going golfing
in the middle of some sort of national
security crisis but you have an entire
FEMA hey you have an entire federal
agency that is that's directive its sole
directive is to watch this stuff do you
think that president from presidents in
the White House is going to make a large
deal of difference when it comes to the
fallout from a hurricane that has not
yet hit land granted is bad optics but
is it really a difference maker and the
role of the presidency in the public
mind is so large and so ridiculous that
we tend to think of
president is sitting over some sort of
desk with control buttons if I just hit
this one right here well that means that
I've stopped the hurricane deploy the
resources Bob pick up the red phone like
the mayor on the old Batman show in any
case here's the Anderson Cooper saying
you know Trump's off golfing and there's
a hurricane about to hit okay whatever
man--
this is 220 seventh day and one of his
golf clubs since he took office
right it would be one thing if he had
not gone after the former president
about golfing and said that he would
never go golfing because he'd be too
busy and doing too important work and
winning so much I mean it's not us
nitpicking it's using his own criteria
of for judging other presidents and by
his own criteria he sure is golfing a
lot okay well again there's there's
there's something fair about that I mean
Trump did go after Barack Obama a lot on
the golfing but I will note somebody who
did not go after Barack Obama a lot on
the golfing and his name is Anderson
Cooper I don't remember
Henderson Cooper doing a lot of stories
about Barack Obama golfing now that it's
Trump's like oh it's terrible I can't
believe that Donald Trump would go
golfing I mean especially when he said
golfing was bad right and you said
golfing wasn't bad and now you think
golfing is bad so this whole thing not
everything is about Trump guys I mean
short story not everything it's about
Trump it's a hurricane we're all on the
same side we would like to see the
hurricane not hurt people and we will
deploy all the resources we can and that
is going to be true whether it is barack
obama or george w bush or donald trump
the prep like this is the most
non-controversial part of being
president is look a disaster let's
deploy the resources that we have
federal taxation to pay for let's do
that thing and who's sitting around like
no neck in a day that this is such
silliness now in a second we're gonna
talk about silliness with regard to
another topic where there should be
unity because that is the name of the
political game these days is that
there's a topic where there should be
some sort of unity and instead we decide
you know what no unity let's scream at
each other for no apparent reason I'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that I have a
lot of leftovers in my fridge I know
fascinating topic but the fact is you
probably have a lot of leftovers too and
I know what happens with that stuff you
throw it in the fridge you're like oh
the kids will eat it and then they don't
eat it you're like I know I will eat it
for sure you don't eat it instead you
wait like four days it starts to grow
ammonia toss it in the garbage
well what if you
a better way of preserving that food so
you can actually eat it later what if
you could save it what if you could make
sure that food was still edible not just
in like a day or two days but in weeks
or months hey your kitchen is filled
with appliances none can save you money
or help you prepare for a natural
disaster or any of the litany of things
that can and will go wrong in your
lifetime until a company in Salt Lake
City had an idea they took an
industrial-sized freeze dryer and then
they found a way to shrink it down for
the average American kitchen which was
pretty awesome
the harvest right freeze dryer is a
revolutionary new way to preserve food
in the comfort and convenience of your
own home it is super cool I mean again
they have entire companies dedicated to
freeze drying food instead you could
just do it in your own house because now
you have the machine no more wasted food
and you can take advantage of deals at
the grocery store you can preserve the
rest for a later date you can make the
healthiest snacks for your family you
can create your own customized home food
storage plan in the event of some sort
of natural disaster like say a hurricane
here is the best part the food can last
for up to 25 years so head on over to
harvest right calm check out this
revolutionary appliance or give them a
call at 803.643.6808
this is happening far too often
obviously but this one was out of the
news within 48 hours and this is always
fascinating to watch because when a mass
shooting happens if it fulfills certain
criteria the media are looking for it
remains in the news forever if it does
not fulfil the criteria the media are
looking for it disappears poof it's gone
right so if it's the El Paso shooting
and it's a white supremacist shooting
Hispanics going aisle to aisle in a
Walmart in the news forever if it is a
shooting at a black church in Charleston
South Carolina in the news forever if it
is a shooting of children in Sandy Hook
Connecticut in the news forever if it's
shooting in parkland Florida in the news
forever if it's a shooting at a gay club
in Orlando nope we don't talk about that
one anymore if it is a shooting at a
church in Texas we don't talk about that
one anymore
it's a shooting in Dayton Ohio we don't
talk about that one anymore and this one
here in Odessa Texas we don't talk about
this one right we there's no need to
talk about this one why because there's
certain criteria the media are looking
for one they're looking for a long gun
or they're looking for somebody who's
using an ar-15 - they're looking for
somebody who is motivated by some sort
of white supremacist or quasi right
beliefs that they can pin on
conservatives and three they're looking
for some sort of mass shooting scenario
in which the motive is not only clear
and convincing but the person who is at
issue is not really on anyone's radar so
much if there are too many red flags
then it tends to fall off right if there
are too many red fluids so you need a
clear motive in order for the media to
lend the motive has to be a some sort of
motive that cannot be attributed to the
left so if it's a if it's an attempted
shooting of congressional the
Congressional baseball players people
playing baseball or in Congress then
that doesn't make the news it has to be
a clear motive the motive has to be a
right-wing motive or something that can
be pinned on the right wing if you're
the media and three it has to be with a
certain type of gun so it's is the
handgun then it doesn't make a
difference which is a long gun that's
what you're looking for those are the
three a motive a motive they can
attribute to the right and it has to be
with a particular type of gun
well this shooting in Odessa did not
fulfill all of those three categories
according to CNN the Odessa Police
Department on Sunday identified the man
who killed seven people and wounded 22
others in a shooting spree in West Texas
now immediately as soon as the spree
started happening this was top of news
obviously because it's big news when
someone goes on a shooting spree this
person it turns out however was not
motivated by any sort of right-wing
beliefs and not only was this person not
motivated by right-wing beliefs there
are a thousand red flag is one of the
criteria - is the media would like for
somebody who didn't trip off any red
flags really because then it can't be
blamed on government failure but then it
can be blamed on the right one generally
it can be blamed on America's tenor of
violence if however it can be blamed on
the authorities missing it over and over
and over and over again then things get
really awkward because the media don't
like that story it is what happened in
parkland in parkland it was the meet it
was the authorities led by the Broward
County Sheriff Scott Israel failing
repeatedly to target the shooter in that
particular case or protect the school
the media just pretended that never
happened and then there there's this big
Town Hall on CNN with Dana
and and with Marco Rubio in which the
right wing was abused while Scott Israel
stood there and grinned with Jake Tapper
presiding that's what the media are
looking for this shooting does not
fulfill any of these criteria so
according to CNN this particular shooter
had been fired from his trucking job
just hours before the rampage killing
according to the New York Times also
this person was arrested in 2001 for
criminal trespass and evading arrest
both misdemeanors according to public
records adjudication was deferred though
the details of the case were not
immediately available also his record
included a 20-18 traffic citation from a
federal motor carrier safety violation
according to exer county court records
apparently the shooter was pulled over
by Texas troopers in Midland on Saturday
afternoon for failing to use his signal
he then shot at the troopers with what
police described as an AR type weapon
and sped away okay so they get one
factor but not the other two driving on
streets and highways he sprayed bullets
randomly at residents and motorists
according to police the man then
hijacked a postal truck and ditched his
gold Honda shooting at people as he made
his way into a Desa about 20 miles away
there police confronted him in a movie
theater parking lot and killed him in a
shootout it is unclear what the motive
was according to investigators the FBI
special agent in charge Christopher
Combs had his agency response to Texas
frequently he said the FBI is quote here
now almost every other week supporting
our local and state partners on active
shooters where almost every two weeks an
active shooter in this country
apparently they're about 15 different
crime scenes now it was pretty clear
early on according to media reports that
there were a thousand red flags that got
missed which again counters why this
thing should be in the news according to
the media if there were red flags it's a
government failure that's bad what the
what the media are looking for is no
government failure an air type weapon
clear motive from the right or at least
something can be pinned on the right you
know something white supremacists they
can pretend as a normal conservative
position even when it totally isn't
okay so ABC News reports that this
Odessa shooter actually called an FBI
headline like 15 minutes before he went
on a shooting spree he called the
National tip line about 15 minutes
before his encounter with the troopers
it was
frankly rambling statements about some
of the atrocities that he felt that he
had gone through he did not make a
threat during that phone call he ended
that phone call after the phone call we
initiated all of our law enforcement
procedures trying to figure out who he
was where he was unfortunately it was
only 15 minutes before they the truthful
was engaged okay so that was one red
flag and then there was another red flag
apparently CNN reported that this
particular shooter threatened to shoot
his neighbor next month and nothing
happened at all that's a pretty big red
flag there guys
he is a 36 year old white man a neighbor
tell CNN that last month he threatened
her with a rifle after she put trash in
a nearby dumpster she says that he would
often shoot into his backyard from a
structure on top of his house and then
go and retrieve dead animals she also
tells us that she called the police
after that incident last month but
claims they never showed up because the
property's location doesn't show up on
GPS and it's hard to find as far as a
motive that is still unknown and the FBI
special agent in charge warns we may
never know well whoopsy doodle
so it turns out that there are all of
these terrible red flags everybody
missed them and that's why you're not
hearing about this shooting anymore it's
not gonna be top of news today it's this
world pass Oh be in the news for weeks
it's not all pass oh so therefore it's
not in the news for even days now as
we'll see the Odessa shooter also failed
a gun background check and we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about why I feel like I need to use a
VPN so just a couple of years ago yeah I
am constantly traveling I use public
Wi-Fi I assume that while I was on
public Wi-Fi somebody actually hacked
some of my credit card passwords and
then proceeded to buy a bunch of NFL
tickets I looked at my charge card I
never really look at my charged bills
until a couple of months later I looked
at my charge card I was like why have I
bought 83 NFL tickets that's weird and
I've never been to an alive I've been
one live NFL game my entire life so
that's kind of odd well it turns out
that somebody had stolen my information
at that point I was like you know what I
should probably have a VPN and that's
when I turned to express VPN you should
be using expressvpn
every time you go online there are too
many people who want your data big tech
companies that are using your data for
their own purposes
governments that are looking for your
data to monitor you particularly if
you're abroad and then you got hacker
we're constantly looking for your data
so that they can use it against you when
I use expressvpn search engines and
media sites can't see my IP address at
all my identity is masked and anonymous
Dazz well expressvpn has the added
benefit of encrypting a hundred percent
of your data to keep you safe from
people you don't want to have that
information Express VPN software it
takes just one minute to set up on your
computer if it really is very easy you
tap one button and you are now protected
I know the dudes who run Express VPN I
definitely trust them with my data which
for me since I'm a public figure is a
pretty important thing protect your
online activity today with the VPN I
trust to keep my data safe visit
expressvpn comm slash bands to claim an
exclusive offer just for my fans
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with the one-year
package visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
to get started go check it out right now
ok so as I say more red flags apparently
the Odessa shooter failed the gun
background check the governor of Texas
Greg Abbott he tweeted on Monday that
the gunman in Saturday's mass shooting
in Midland and Odessa had previously
failed the gun purchase background check
did not go through a background check to
buy the gun used in Saturday's incident
whoops another thing that cuts against
this being in the news if it turns out
there are regulations that were already
violated then what another regulation
have stopped any of this the answer of
course is no Abbot's we didn't say
according to the Texas Tribune why the
36 year old Odessa man didn't pass the
background check or how he obtained the
rifle he used to kill seven people and
injured 22 others Abbott also cited the
shooters criminal history said we must
keep guns out of criminals hands now
this should be an area of relative
unanimity as I say the left doesn't have
the ability to blame it on the right
this is obviously a bunch of red flags
that were ignored a bunch of government
failures this guy violated a bunch of
regulations so additional regulations
probably would not have helped here and
yet somehow this is still become a
partisan issue because if we can make a
hurricane partisan man we can make
anything partisan and if it's not
partisan enough and it just sort of
drops off the table in the news cycle
it's no longer there well leading the
charge this time in the gun control
battle is Joe Biden who's been looking
for sort of a rationale for being in the
race the big problem for Joe Biden is
that he still can't answer a very simple
question why are you running right this
is one of the big problems for Hillary
Clinton in 2016 Bernie Sanders could
tell you why he's running he wants more
pudding of course but actually he was
running because you
it's more socialism Hillary Clinton kept
being asked why she was running and it
was basically because I deserve it and
Joe Biden is the same thing if you ask
Joe Biden why he's running he'll talk
about the soul of the country and all
this stuff but what it really feels like
is he's running because he's real old
and he's run 1 million times before
and who's Barack Obama's VP and
shouldn't you just sort of hand it to
him like a Lifetime Achievement Award
it's like the Oscars and you know
somebody's about the plot so you give
them the Lifetime Achievement Award well
there's a problem for Joe Biden so he's
been looking for some sort of spice in
his campaign and the media are picking
up on this the media love love level of
Elizabeth Warren and we'll get to
senator Warren in just a second because
her career is sort of fascinating it's
fascinating how she moved from a sort of
heterodox I kind of clastic thinker into
somebody who is doctrinaire on the Left
Bernie Sanders type because she didn't
use to be but Joe Biden the reason the
media are out of love with him right now
is because he can't answer that simple
question so the New York Times has a
piece today by mark Leibovich titled
does Joe Biden want to be doing this
which is always good sign for your
campaign do you even want to be here Joe
how badly do you want to be President
Joseph R Biden was asked after a recent
speech in pro Iowa the answer to such an
inquiry would appear self-evident in the
case of mr. Biden who began his running
for president routine more than three
decades ago in other words very badly
one would assume but the question posed
by a reporter seems to come and mr.
Biden as a bit of a curveball a variant
of the why do you want to be president
riddle that CBS is Roger Mudd famously
stumped Ted Kennedy with 40 years ago
the former VP paused I think it's really
really really important that Donald
Trump not be reelected Biden said which
is more of a rationale than an answer
that's true I mean that when the New
York Times says that's more of a
rationale than an answer correct but
that doesn't explain why you want to be
president that explains why you don't
want Donald Trump to be President he
then launched into a classic Biden
roller derby of verbiage in which he
listed all the reasons he found Trump so
distasteful he lands it on a question to
himself could I die happily not having
heard hail to the chief played for me he
said yeah I could that's not why I'm
running so why is he running says the
New York Times and is the singular
nature of the opponent's all it will
take to convince voters that Joe Biden
really wants to be doing this right now
at this vicious moments in our politics
at this stage of his life
remarkably after all this time mr. Biden
stumbles to come up with a clear answer
his use of mr.
as a campaign mission statement might be
a good enough reason at least to win
Biden the Democratic nomination in a
large field were two other leading
candidates Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders appear to be splitting the
progressive vote which would be less
inclined to support him to begin with
Biden's campaign has been jackhammering
home the premise that he is best suited
to winning a general election against an
incumbent who must not be reelected I
needed done who used to work for the
Obama White House she says he doesn't
think you need a revolution here instead
it's a strategic bet according to the
New York Times that given the
possibility of another four years of
Trump Democrats will gravitate to the
familiar and reach for this stitched up
old teddy bear of a candidate he brutal
okay but that is the reality so Joe
Biden has been looking for a rationale
for why he is running because while his
numbers are fairly durable so far if he
can't answer that question sometime in
here it's going to be a serious problem
for him right now he's running in the
low 30s but let's say that we go another
year another year remember it's still
September right the the nominee is not
going to be determined in the Democratic
Party until July of next year so it's
gonna be another ten nine ten months of
this routine if Joe Biden can't come up
with a better answer for why are you
running for president then I really
really dislike Trump then it's over for
you buddy well so Biden is looking for a
rationale when he thinks maybe he's
found it and gun control now he's not
good at this this is part of the problem
for Joe Biden and so even when he's
making the case in favor of gun control
he literally has no idea what he is
talking about this is a guy who once
suggested that he bought a pump-action
shotgun so that if somebody came on his
property and was a criminal
you could either blast through a door
which would be probably a bad idea cuz
you don't know who's on the other end of
it or that he would go out onto the
balcony of his home and fire the gun
into the air which is like something
that he saw from an old western with
Charlton Heston or something but here is
Joe Biden over the weekend suggesting
that his solution on this is a ban on
magazines he said any magazine that
holds a bullet which is literally what a
magazine is meant to do so what is he
talking about we're all gonna start
turning in every semi-automatic weapon
and using revolvers and old bolt-action
rifles and what the hell is he talking
about here it has to stop the idea that
we
elimination of assault-type weapons
magazines that can can hold multiple
bullets in them is absolutely - there's
no violation the Second Amendment it is
it's just a vow to the special interest
of the gun manufacturers you know right
okay so any gun that can hold multiple
bullets he wants to ban and that's
bowing to the NRA wasn't one of the
things that is so irritating about gun
control talk for the left is that people
do not become pro-gun because the NRA
exists the NRA exists because people are
pro-gun it's like saying that that
Planned Parenthood in the absence of
Planned Parenthood there would be no
push for abortion no Planned Parenthood
exists because there was a push for
abortion emily's list exists because
there's a push for abortion the nra is
no different it will get you more of the
Democrats trying to find a raise intent
the reason to exist by pushing gun
control in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that we are all
going to die I know depressing for the
day after a Labor Day weekend but it's a
reality man and that is why you should
be looking at policy genius right now
because if you know you're gonna plot
and you do take five minutes think about
it then never think about it again but
make sure that your family is insured
September is National Life Insurance
Awareness Month most exciting month of
the year most people may not be aware of
this little fact in fact most people
aren't even aware they need life
insurance at all which is why 40% of
Americans don't have it so this math
doesn't line up forty percent of
Americans don't have life insurance but
100 percent of Americans will die so
this doesn't make any sense if you don't
have life insurance and you are an adult
do some adult thing and get life
insurance right now especially because
prices are the lowest they have been in
20 years policy genius has made it
easier than ever to get covered policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape again policy
genius makes it supremely easy they
don't just do life insurance by the way
they do home insurance and auto
insurance and disability insurance so if
you need life insurance but you just
haven't gotten around to it national
life insurance awareness month you are
now aware so go do it policy genius calm
yet quotes apply in minute you can do
the whole thing on your phone right this
very moment policy genius the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance okay
so it's not just Joe Biden out on the
campaign trail trying to claim that we
should get rid of magazines that hold
multiple bullets which like good luck
with that
also Biden
that President Trump doesn't have the
intestinal fortitude to pass gun control
because Joe Biden is a man of courage
while he's stumbling into trees and such
[Music]
intestinal fortitude to deal with Eno's
there is no solution the solution is to
win well I seem to recall that you were
vice president for eight years and for
several of those years at the very
beginning of the presidency you had
basically 60 votes in the Senate that's
how you got Obamacare and yet you didn't
do anything on this topic weird weird
Biden also stumbled and bumbled over the
Constitution here he says well the
Constitution doesn't say anyone can own
a weapon the Constitution does pretty
much say that so long as you're not a
criminal that's kind of what the Second
Amendment basically says it's a right to
keep and bear arms so yeah I does
actually every single solitary amendment
has a limitation on it now the
limitation that exists on on on the
Second Amendment is no where does it say
you can own any kind of weapon you want
no or does it say no no where does it
say anyone can own a weapon and those
who say maybe some do and I'm that the
tree of liberty is watered with the
blood of patriots meaning you got to be
able to have enough power to take on
your government well you need an f-15
you need an m1 tank you need
flamethrowers you need bazookas you need
no I'm serious if that's the rationale
okay well no that's actually not a
serious argument considering the fact
that small arms have typically been a
fairly good method of resisting a major
power is Joe Biden well knows but in any
case Joe Biden stumblin it doesn't say
anyone can Oh a kind of does right I
mean as long as you are an adult right
with very minor restrictions
it basically says if you're a law
abiding citizen then you can own a
weapon okay so it's not just Biden doing
this it's also bado or rob a doe
desperately looking for rationale for
his campaign and he has also stumbled on
gun control because of the shooting in
El Paso he says he's just gonna start
confiscating semi-automatic weapons yes
I'm sure that not nothing from
people coming together quite like saying
that you're going to take 150 200
million Americans and just forcibly
remove their guns from them this is I'm
sure this is gonna go great for bait oh
yeah so I want to be really clear that
that's exactly what we're going to do
Americans will who own ar-15s ak-47s
will have to sell them to the government
we're not going to allow them to stay on
our streets to show up in our
communities okay so here not going to
allow how is he gonna do this with his
magic president thing powers this is one
of the problems with the idea of the
president is dictator this is not how
any of this works now one of the things
that makes you anonymity nearly
impossible in the country right now and
it makes it impossible to even have
rational discussions even about things
like gun control is that we don't trust
our neighbors and if we did trust our
neighbors maybe we wouldn't want the
government coming in and invading the
rights of our neighbors so much and one
second we're gonna get to why exactly we
don't trust our neighbors and the answer
is maybe your neighbor is a jackass
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire calm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month or $99 a year you can
subscribe to daily wire.com I'll tell
you why you should do this not only when
you get the annual subscriptions you get
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels cast your eyes upon it and weep
that you have it not the leftist year's
hot or cold tumbler not only do you get
that but you also get to be part of the
team and this really does help us
because as we'll see in a moment the
left is firmly intent on destroying
anyone who disagrees with them they play
this game where you have a conversation
with someone you disagree with and
suddenly you're the bad guy this is the
game the left wants to play and they
want to make it utterly unpalatable for
views they disagree with to be aired in
public and so when you subscribe you
actually help us make sure that we have
the resources to go around they're
gatekeepers and make sure that you can
get the sort of content that you want
here it's a Lee Weyer really is helping
us out helping yourself out helping the
First Amendment now when you go to daily
wire.com put your money where your
belief system is and join the team over
here at the other what we really do
appreciate it our employees appreciate
it I know that all of our listeners
appreciate it
come join hey Lee Weyer right now we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so we are now in a vicious cycle of
distrust right we have decided that
because some people in our community
wants use the government to come after
us that we distrust those people and
then those people decide that because
they distrust you they want the
government to go after you
so it's this vicious cycle of of
mistrust and this is why for example red
flag gun laws which seem like they make
a lot of sense they rely on the idea
that your neighbor isn't gonna call the
cops on you just because you have a
political disagreement right the red
flag gun laws are the idea that a
neighbor a friend they see something bad
happening they call the cops and now
there can be a preliminary removal of
your guns for the moment
well we ascertain what exactly is going
on okay and frankly I don't have a
general problem with this idea the
problem is that you may have your
next-door neighbor who just wants to
remove your guns by ten to the fact they
disagree with you and evidence of this
comes from our good friends in Hollywood
so remember that time when Hollywood was
super pissed off because supposedly it
was a wide breach of American values to
target actual communist agents inside
Hollywood there are the McCarthy
hearings and this was apparently the
worst thing that ever happened in the
United States now McCarthy hearings were
quite bad but worst thing to ever happen
in the United States not so much people
are gonna say I'm strong Manning that
how many films is Hollywood made about
the McCarthy era approximately 1 million
six hundred and twenty three thousand
two hundred and eleven I mean they they
make a movie about the McCarthy era
every five minutes meanwhile they are
McCarthyite hey the highest levels of
Hollywood are McCarthy i'ts it's the
reason why I have a number of fairly
prominent Hollywood people that I talk
to when I say fairly prominent I mean a
listers who I talk to on a fairly
regular basis and I will never ever
reveal who they are specifically because
then the left would come and ruin their
career then the left would come in and
suggest that these people should not be
able to talk to me it mainstream
conservative because this inherently
makes them very very bad and you've seen
this over and over with anybody who even
has a conversation with people on the
right I have literally met in
restaurants in Los Angeles wearing a
baseball cap and sunglasses with people
in Hollywood on like early Sunday
mornings when no one else is around
because people are afraid that they're
going to be spotted by other forces in
Hollywood who call them out for even
having met with a prominent conservative
it truly is unbelievable
well listen I'm willing to meet with
pretty much anybody I have met with all
sorts of very very prominent famous
people in a wide variety of industries I
will
ever reveal who those people are because
frankly it's nobody's damn business and
the fact is that Hollywood and
journalists who are out there they wish
to harm people who will even text with
people have conversations of people so
here is a perfect example
so Andy Lassner is a really nice guy any
last Neurol so happens to be a producer
on Ellen and this means that he can be
shamed he can be shamed
now Andy Lassner good dude right I've
dealt with him a little bit on Twitter
seems like a really nice guy he's
friends via Sharlee another really nice
guy who I've dealt with on Twitter Andy
Lassner he tweeted out after this latest
shooting here's the truth I don't have
the answer to the gun problem the mass
shootings I don't want to take guns away
from law-abiding citizens many people in
my life own guns but we must have a
serious but we have a serious problem
and we must start talking about gun
violence solutions in a bipartisan way
this is he there's what we call a
reasonable treat like like I think a
reasonable person would say to another
reasonable person
so Dana lash who used to be a
spokesperson for the NRA and now she's a
radio host right she was radio host then
now that's what she does because she's
no longer with the NRA she tweeted out
we have to penalize agencies that do not
submit all prohibited cases to NCIC
that'd be the federal registry
Charleston Sutherland Springs those are
examples of where the local agencies did
not submit the proper reports to the
national database she says they're not
following the law also we need to stop
coddling dangerous offenders in their
youth by preventing establishment of
criminal record and she points out
Dayton Ohio and parkland Florida these
are cases where young people who are
under the age of 18 have done bad things
in their past criminal things and then
we have no registry of that so the cops
cannot remove them of their guns and and
elastin or tweets back well this is
definitely a start okay this is what we
call a reasonable conversation where
Andy Lassner says you know it'd be great
some solutions and then Dana comes back
and says here are a couple things and he
says this is a good idea
Erin Roop are an alleged reporter for
voxcom immediately tweets out quote it's
silly to earnestly engage with the
former paid and are a gonna show on the
topic of preventing gun violence first
of all you want to talk of paid shills
dude works for Vox second of all it's
silly to earnestly engage like you can't
have a conversation with anybody if you
have a conversation you're a very bad
person the way that the left would like
to treat people on the right this is why
we can't have any sort of regulation
that rely on public trust because the
public trust is gone
if you treat your neighbor like they are
a leper from the leper colony in
Papillon the original that if you get in
that if you talk if Andy Lassner talks
with Dana lash then Dana lash is like a
whip press character and she's going to
infect him with her leprosy and Erin
Rupert is there to police the boundary
he's there to stop you from having that
conversation why the hell would I allow
people like Erin rooper to control
regulations or legislation why would I
trust a neighbor like Erin Rupert why
would I do that the answer is I would
not and most Americans would not and
it's true in journalism right that you
have this whole this whole cadre of
ledged journalists whose sole job it is
apparently to prevent conversation from
happening between moderate left and
moderate right to prevent any sort of
discussion from happening if you have
that person on your podcast then you are
a bad man you're a bad person if you
have a conversation with that person
you're a bad person if you say maybe
that person's well-intentioned you're a
bad person that's the same thing in
Hollywood so as I say it's in journalism
and it's also in Hollywood last nurs in
Hollywood so that means that Rupert
thinks he's subject to his blackmail and
he's not subject to anybody's blackmail
he's his own thinker it's ridiculous
okay but it's not just that you had Will
and Grace the stars of Will and Grace
over the weekend come out and suggest
that they wanted the names of anybody in
Hollywood who supported Trump so now we
are going the full Joaquin Castro in
Texas route remember walking cast or the
representative in Texas he tweeted out
the names of all the Trump donors in his
district half of whom supported him to
because he's a jerk he's a jerk it's The
Hollywood Reporter tweeted out President
Donald Trump to appear at Beverly Hills
fundraiser during Emmys week now I
happen to know some of the people who
are going to this fundraiser because I
know most of the prominent Republicans
in the city Eric McCormack who was one
of the actors on Will & Grace and he's
also the guy from travelers if you've
seen that on Netflix need to get out hey
Hollywood Reporter kindly report on
everyone attending this event so the
rest of us can be clear about who we
don't want to work with Thanks in other
words I want to blackmail everybody who
disagrees with me politically if anybody
gives money to Donald Trump I will never
work with them ever ever ever again yeah
I trust you guys to be part of the
common community where we trust each
other and we don't call the authorities
unless we need to
and we never
use the power of the government gun to
point it at our friends I definitely
trust you guys and Debra Messing also of
Will & Grace then tweets out please
Prince a list of all attendees please
the public has a right to know the
public has a right to know how
delightful she is I mean what's
delightful people these folks are
President Trump then tweeted his own
response he says I have not forgotten
that when it was announced that I was
going to do the apprentice and when it
became a big head helping NBC's fares
line up greatly Debra Messing came up to
me at an upfront and profusely thanked
me even calling me sir
how times have changed one of the things
that drives Hollywood so nuts about
Trump is that they created him he is
their Frankenstein monster Donald Trump
was basically a d-list celebrity until
The Apprentice and then The Apprentice
happens and he becomes an a-list
celebrity again and he's appearing on
the Emmy singing Greenacres with one of
the stars of Will & Grace Megan Mullaly
I'd say that that's pretty ironic and
pretty hilarious but the larger point is
that you cannot have a community or a
republic in which people are forbidden
from having conversations with each
other and where people are deliberately
attempting to destroy each other's lives
so here is another example of this
outside of Hollywood so there are these
there's this couple names Carl and angel
Larson hey and this couple is now in the
middle of a lawsuit a federal a federal
appeals court lawsuit just reinstated a
lawsuit filed by these two Minnesota
filmmakers they want the right to refuse
to film the same-sex weddings they said
that videos are a form of speech with
constitutional protections under the
First Amendment so Carl and angel Larson
run a Christian business called
Telescope Media Group and st. cloud is
according to the AP they sued the
state's Human Rights Commissioner in
saying Minnesota's public accommodation
law would result in steep fines in jail
time if they offered services promoting
only their vision of marriage so they
their videographers they only do
traditional marriages and the state of
Minnesota basically threatened them with
jail if they would not create videos on
behalf of same-sex couples because this
is America guys and we can't have people
creating the videos that want to create
a federal judge dismissed the case two
years ago but a three-judge panel of the
8th US Circuit Court of Appeals reversed
that decision on Friday the panel sent
the case back to the lower court with
instructions to consider a preliminary
injunction
that would allow the Larson's to operate
their business without fear of being
found in violation of Minnesota's Human
Rights Act according to the Star Tribune
Judge David Straus is a former Minnesota
Supreme Court justice he wrote in
Friday's opinion that wedding videos
involve editorial judgment and control
and constituted a media for the
communication of ideas which is
obviously true judge Jane Kelly issued a
dissenting opinion she said that the
service the Larson's want to make
available to the public is expressive
does not transform Minnesota's law into
a content-based regulation nor should it
empower the Larson's to discriminate
against prospective customers based on
sexual orientation is another perfect
example of neighbors not leaving each
other alone hey the Republic relies how
neighbors leaving each other alone if we
don't leave each other alone it's gonna
be extraordinarily difficult for us to
have any common politics at all and this
is what we are watching in action this
is why politics continue to become so
partisan because if I don't trust you
and you don't trust me and the only
question is who gets to control the gun
that shoots the other guy well then
politics is basically bloodsport
now speaking of bloodsport you wanna
know somebody for whom politics has
become bloodsport is Elizabeth Warren so
senator Warren is obviously running
strong in the Democratic primaries right
now not quite as strong as I think a lot
of the media would have it by which I
mean that if you look at the poll
averages right now nationally she is
still running third there's a lot of
talk about her being the the new
frontrunner the polls are pretty
conflicted about that there are a couple
of polls that came out in the last week
the last two polls had Joe Biden up
seven points and Joe Biden up four
points respectively only one of those
polls had Elizabeth Warren in second
place that was the Economist YouGov poll
that had Biden up over her 25 to 21 the
emerson poll had her down in third
trailing tro biden by 16 points in fact
on average in the last maybe seven or
eight polls
she has down somewhere between 13 and 17
points to Joe Biden in most of these
polls so for all the talk about her
being the new frontrunner that is a
little premature however it is sort of
fascinating to watch Elizabeth Warren's
transformation as a candidate so I've
only met Elizabeth Warren one time I did
in her class when I was at Harvard Law
and I was like this isn't for me she's
to teach property but I did take a
sample class with her when I was at
Harvard Law School she was a good
teacher I mean I will say that she was
very live in the classroom she's very
charismatic in the classroom
the very first time I met her I've told
this story before I met her when she was
recruiting for Harvard Law School is at
the top of the W Hotel very swanky in
Los Angeles and the what near the
Westwood campus and I went up there and
she was sort of wandering around meeting
all the students and she realized that I
was the guy who had written a book about
college by us on campus and she had said
well I don't really think that there is
liberal bias on college campus are you
sure that's the case and I was like yeah
that's the case and she said oh you're
one of those rush limbaugh listeners
aren't you I said have you ever listened
to Rush Limbaugh and she was like no so
that's sort of how our conversation
started that was the only really lengthy
conversation I ever had with now senator
Warren but here's the thing way back in
2003 2004 which is when I met her she
was a much more interesting thinker so
this is the thing to understand about
Elizabeth Warren that because our
politics now revolves around demonizing
other people and government control
heterodox thinkers like Elizabeth Warren
circa 2003 are no longer tolerated by by
homogeneous thinkers circa Elizabeth
Warren 2019 Elizabeth Warren 2019 is not
Elizabeth Moore in 2003 how do I know
well over the weekend I read her book
she wrote this very famous book called
the to income trap in 2003 and the book
is actually really really interesting
and she used to be sort of an
interesting thinker the to income trap
is premise on this basic idea which is
that the number of females who had who
had gone into bankruptcy had risen
spectacularly over the past two or three
decades which she found kind of shocking
because she figured okay well it really
should be a lot of males going into
bankruptcy after all more females are
entering the workforce particularly
mothers mother and it wasn't just single
moms it was married moms who were going
into bankruptcy and what she found is
that there was something called the two
income trap happening the two income
trap was basically a lot of women
entered the workforce with the guarantee
that they would now have two incomes in
the family which meant more money for
everybody and then what would happen is
one person they would then take out
expenses that were commensurate with the
combined salary of the couple so let's
say one and a half the couple's making
50 grand the others making 50 grand
their combined income is now 100 grand
so they take out a mortgage on a house
that is commensurate with 100 grand
income and then one of them loses their
job well now they're in bankruptcy so
her actual point is that the same did
not hold true if you had one income so
you have one income
50 grand and you take out expenses
commensurate with that 50 grand
including getting a smaller house then
the husband loses his job we have a
backup earner sort of in store in the
woman she would then enter the workforce
and she'd make up like 60% of the salary
while Dad was looking for a job
whereas if you are living on the edge of
two salaries and there's no backup plan
you're basically screwed that was the
two income trap and her suggestion was
that so many women had entered the
workforce that it had artificially
increased prices on things like housing
particularly in the suburbs it's a
really interesting sort of take right I
mean her she's not arguing women
shouldn't be in the workforce but she is
arguing that women in the workforce does
have an enormous number of unintended
consequences and that maybe the couples
that are best situated are actually the
ones where only one member of the family
is working because you're only gonna
take out expenses commensurate with one
salary and really a really interesting
take and not only is that take pretty
interesting she also talks about
specific policy proposals and her policy
proposals are fairly interesting
including some fairly right-wing policy
proposals right she argued explicitly
against more government regulation of
the housing market she slams complex
regulations since they quote might
actually worsen the situation by
diminishing the incentive to build new
houses or improve older ones weird
because now her entire party is calling
for rent control and government
subsidized housing right she favored
against sheefish in instead of trying to
place restrictions on housing building
and and caps on prices she suggested a
well-designed voucher program that's
right Elizabeth Warren used to be a big
fan of school vouchers because she
pointed out the reason that people were
moving into suburbs was to get to better
schools and he had school vouchers than
people from inner cities could actually
go to those better schools and that
would allow more free transport of
people to better schools and that would
bring down overall real estate prices
that's a very right-wing proposal
hey the heterodox policy proposals
didn't actually stop there she quote she
refused to quote join the chorus calling
for tax taxpayer-funded daycare on its
own right now she says oh we need
taxpayer-funded daycare for everybody
it's a great idea to work out great she
actually called that a sacred cow in
2003 at the very least she suggested
that quote government subsidized daycare
would add one more indirect
mothers to join the workforce in other
words it removed the incentive for mom
to stay home if the government was
actually subsidizing daycare so she
suggested that it would have to be part
of a broader comprehensive program
including tax credits for stay-at-home
parents in fact she ardently opposed
additional taxpayer subsidized ation of
college loans she said that we should
not be subsidizing college loans no more
like now if she proposes that we remove
all student debt right we pay off
everybody's college loans and now she's
coming out in bed and she was saying no
taxpayer subsidies subsidization of
college loans and no taxpayer spending
on higher education directly instead she
called for a tuition freeze from state
schools she also recommended tax
incentives for families to save rather
than spend now she calls for a wealth
tax right now she says she said then
that it would be income graduated would
be wealth graduated but it cuts against
the basic idea read she wants to
actually incentivize saving now she
wants to penalize savings and this is my
favorite quote from her book she opposed
radical solutions wholesale there's a
direct quote from Elizabeth Warren circa
2003 quote we haven't suggested a
complete overhaul of the tax structure
we haven't demanded the businesses cease
and desist from ever closing another
plant or firing another worker nor have
we suggested that the United States
should build a quasi socialist safety
net to rival the European model direct
quote from Elizabeth war in 2003 does
this sound like Elizabeth Warren 2019 no
it doesn't she heard a new intro for
this book in 2016 with her daughter cuz
the book is written with her daughter
and now it is just boilerplate
Democratic PAP why because Elizabeth
Warren understands that creative
solutions are not possible in a country
where we don't trust one another that
when you mistrust your neighbor that the
only solution is absolute power and so
Elizabeth Warren has opted for absolute
power just like the rest of the
Democratic Party
she has opted for top-down government
control in every area because half the
solutions she's calling for rely on you
trusting your neighbor and suggesting
your neighbor isn't a bad person so she
has jettisoned that now she is in full
scale your neighbors a bad person
territory and if they stray then we
clock them that is not an inherently
sympathetic positions whether Americans
it's amazing that so many on the Left
can portray themselves as sympathetic to
their fellow Americans when their actual
proposal is that other Americans for
making free choices ought to be punished
in a general way
and the government ought to cram down
their fridge and if you even have
conversations across the aisle in the
most extreme cases of the left then you
should be punished just for those
conversations Elizabeth Warren used to
be an interesting character she's no
longer interesting which is why she's
now seen as a frontrunner for the
Democratic Party nomination Elizabeth
Warren circa 2003 was actually kind of
interesting
2019 she's it boring as mud she's absent
she is her new ideas are Bernie Sanders
his ideas and they're just as bad okay
time for a quick thing I like and then a
quick thing that I hate okay so things
that I like today so I have to credit to
this Florida man there's always a
Florida man and he was talking about how
to fight hurricanes and he was
suggesting well you know people keep
saying that warming waters are making
the velocity of hurricanes faster
because it's easier for the hurricane to
churn off of the top layer of water
because of the because of the water
temperature he has an idea let him spell
it out for you see how they ever come up
with some kind of way to come come back
these storms yet they keep saying warm
water we have a navy why don't the Navy
come and drop ice in the warm water so
it thought they can't get going as fast
as it's going the wind what we have an
Air Force
5.if which planes around to get the
winds going the opposite way um yeah so
that's a solution I mean listen we can
make fun of the sky all day but we know
he'll be president by 2024 so we should
really watch ourselves here I mean at
the very least it's a better solution
than nuking the hurricane so I mean I'm
not I'm not against it maybe that was
maybe that was presidents from original
plan where he's actually to buy
Greenland and then he was going to ship
it glacier by glacier into the hurricane
pathway just to stop those hurricane I
don't know you don't know he's a
creative thinker hey other things that I
like today so there is a very good
editorial in the Washington Post today
by a Chinese dissident named Chen
Guangcheng he's a member of the Faculty
of the Institute for Policy Research and
Catholic studies at the Catholic
University of America and he talks about
President Trump and his stance against
China he says as someone who has spent
years with the knife edge of the Chinese
Communist Party bearing down on my
throat for my human
Wright's work I know the president is
onto something tariffs and economic
threats may be blunt tools but they are
the kind of aggressive tactics necessary
to get the attention of the CCP regime
which respects only power and money it's
not just about winning as the president
sometimes puts it and it's not simply
about trade it's about justice it's
about doing what's right for ordinary
Chinese and American people presidents
before Trump naively believed that China
would abide by international standards
of behavior if it were granted access to
institutions like the WTO and generally
treated as a normal country but that
path proved mistaken Beijing ignored
Western pressure on matters from human
rights to the widespread theft of
intellectual property Trump whatever his
flaws grasps this reality ok that is a
truth and the media basically refused to
acknowledge it so at least good for the
Washington Post for printing this
particular op-ed by Chen Guangcheng you
know I think we are actually out of time
so we're gonna skip the things that I
hate today
because a love filled day guys and we'll
be back here a little bit later today
with many more things that I hate two
additional hours of things that I hate
later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20:19 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you